So the first thing we want to do as we saw in the the diagrams that we were
going through before is that we want to create a new blueprint class. So the way
I do this more often than not is to right-click on the content folder go to
new folder I'm going to type this blueprints. I generally like to create
a new folder for blueprints and then what I'll even probably do is
create a new folder here called maybe let's call it interactions. The naming
convention is completely up to you of what you want to use but you can imagine if
we're doing multiple blueprints here and we've got different types of
blueprints maybe there's a player blueprint maybe maybe there's something
that's not an interaction maybe it's a pickup blueprint for example it's just
good to start organizing your blueprints and getting used to the flow. So inside
of the interactions folder I'm going to right-click and select blueprint class
and we're gonna find this pick parent class box that we saw in the
PowerPoint previously. Now I don't because we're creating a door we don't
need any of this other functionality. An actor is an object that can be placed
or spawned in the world and because we're placing the door in the world that
it makes sense to pick actor here. So I'm just gonna select actor and it's
going to create a new blueprint down here and I'm going to call this BP
underscore and BP is essentially just blueprint underscore and I'm gonna call
this door so BP door and hit enter. Now getting used to good naming conventions
again will help your journey in blueprints and keep organization nice
and clean. In this example we're gonna go for BP underscore which is a good
naming convention to take forward using blueprints but again go ahead and use
whatever naming conventions that you'd prefer to use. I'm going to double
click this blueprint and it's going to open the blueprint editor. I'm just
going to dock this blueprint window at the top of my screen. I'm just going to
go to file save all and okay we're in a good place. So the first thing we want
to do is add our door frame to this blueprint class. So again we're
going to use this components window that's on the left hand side here
which we spoke about before saying that we'll get a visual representation of all
our blueprint components. One thing I always keep forgetting about Unreal
Engine 5 that's what you used to have to do in Unreal Engine 4 but anywhere in
the editor now we can just hit ctrl and spacebar which brings up the window
so this makes our lives much easier. So no matter which window you're in you
just want to hit ctrl and spacebar and we want to select the door frame. So
as long as we have the door frame selected now we can go to add and
you'll see static mesh SM underscore door frame. Now if you can't see that
door frame it's likely that you didn't select it in your quick draw so just
make sure you have that selected and then we'll go to add and we'll go to
static mesh. So if we just zoom out here the navigation that I'm using to
for zooming by the way is left mouse button will pan me around and right
mouse button will rotate the camera. Both can go up and down so both left
mouse button and right mouse button together will go up and down. So again
you can just get familiar with that interaction there. Just good practice
every time I add a component I'm just gonna hit compile I'm gonna hit save
compile compiles like code now compile even though we've not got any
blueprint code per se we added something to the blueprint which needs
to be checked if it needs compiling so we got a green tick we're good and we
forgot the save button but I'm gonna hit ctrl and spacebar again I'm gonna
select the door the exact same functionality now so I'm going to go to
add door and because our world zero our central point of this blueprint is in
the middle and our door frame has a pivot that's in the middle and our door
actually has a pivot that's on its left hand side here because it needs to
rotate from that origin we just need to make sure we move this across. Now if
your door is snapping like this you'll see there's some grid snapping and some
rotation snapping so I can either toggle the grid down to a lower number so
I'm just using my bracket keys on the keyboard or I can hit five units
and see if that snaps okay we're good there so the door's been made to a
unit snap of five and it looks like it's got a nice fitting all over so
again I'm just going to compile and save I'm going to get into the habit of
doing that each time next thing we want to do now we definitely want to go
into the first person map we want to hit ctrl and spacebar I'm going to
navigate up to my blueprints folder I'm going to grab my blueprint and drag
and drop it in the map and here we have our first blueprint in the game
if we hit play we can see there's a door here it's not got any
functionality we bang into the door we can't go through the door yet but
we've created our first blueprint which will now add code to